the idea of regression
ghost back to what?
You know Sir Francis Galton.
talked about in his
in his literature
There's a court where he says each.
Particularly peculiari is man is
shared by Kinsman, but on average tallest degree now, there
are different ways to interpret this.
quote from him and there is
this phenomena that he's trying to talk about that
has to do not just with people but
different things in nature, for example
When we say regression we talk about this thing called this concept
of regressing back to the mean.
for example, if you look at people human
beings
when a when when
two people that their offspring tend to
be taller than them on average two people when they
have when they have children they tend to be taller than
their parents.
and this happens
You know.
Over time The Descendants their children
have kids they're tall already. They don't have kids
they become taller still.
But eventually they will start to regress back to
average height. So if you take people who are really tall
exceptionally tall.
Their children can go up to seven feet seven foot
five seven foot six, you know like yell me.
Who was the NBA player?
But it doesn't continue like this forever. Like it's it's
not as if people started to go like there are some
exceptional cases where people were eight feet eight feet tall, maybe even
a little more than that.
But they won't go up to 20 feet tall eventually at
some point.
They will start to like you you will find people who are who
are very tall very very tall, but the
children are shorter than them shorter than them.
and it and
gradually their offspring to start to become
short of still.
So you see shorter people have taller kids but taller kids start to
have shorty kids and they if you
if you look at all of these.
Experiments these experiments where we have birth and these children
grow up to become adults. They started cluster.
towards the mean
average the average height of people
This is not just true with like the heights of
people. It's true with.
many things how self-populate how
diseases spread
so many examples like in the financial Market.
but the idea is
there is this.
truth
in this world where we live in where things start to
go to extremes, but eventually they'll come
back.
to averages
Okay.
here
Francis golden has talked about people who are exceptional. They make
too much. They're too rich or let's say they're too
fast or they're too intelligent, but there are times
where even they will start to see a decline.